Usually during the midterm elections, the party in power suffers from a lack of enthusiasm.
But with Trump's doubling down on fearmongering and falsities,
he's whipping up his base yet again.
It is concerning if they're taking our jobs and they’re taking our benefits.
This town is 95% white.
There aren't any immigrants coming to this town, so how are they taking your jobs?
Well, they’re not.
What does?
And who are these people, exactly?
We came here to Jamestown, Tennessee,
a tiny town of just under 2,000 residents, to find out why Trump's message resonates so well with people here
who feel abandoned by the government.
There are places all over the United States like this that's forgotten, nobody's ever heard of.
Here in Jamestown, 95% of the population is white. It's also one of the poorest towns in America.
There's really not a lot of jobs around here.
- That's what I've heard.
We used to have a lot of factories and stuff here.
Between 2008-2012, Jamestown had the sixth lowest median
household income of any place in the entire country.
But during the first 100 days of Donald Trump's presidency, Tennessee quickly
saw a surge in small business job growth.
Do you feel that things got better since 2016?
- I think so.
Really?
Do you feel things got better since 2016?
- I think so.
Really?
I do better, myself. You see a lot more businesses starting up, evidently because of Trump. I don’t know.
I think the economy got a little bit better, but it’s still got a long way to go.
Who do you blame for things getting so bad?
- I don’t like to point fingers at anybody, but I believe it’s the government as a whole, really.
He's talking about Mexican criminals.
He's talking about Middle Eastern people invading America from the border.
Do you think that that resonates with people here?
Yeah, I believe it does. They believe whatever they hear.
It’s not bad anymore to be a racist or anything.
I don’t understand why. I just don’t have an answer.
Here in Fentress County, Tennessee, President Trump won 82.5% of the vote in 2016.
He talks about Mexican criminals, he talks about terrorists,
he talks about grabbing women by the p*ssy.
When he says all those things, what do you think?
I think he needs to keep his mouth shut, too.
He shouldn't try to influence the American people to feel a certain way.
I mean, that's his opinion, that's how he feels, keep it to yourself.
I think that's what he don't really realize, how much impact he has.
Do you see a connection at all between the level of hateful rhetoric
and these kinds of hate crimes happening?
Probably.
You see bombs sent in the mail to these people, you know what I mean?
Aw, you think that?
I think that.
Really?
- Yeah.
It used to be all, “Aw, we can't say that," but now it's like,
“Eh! We don't care anymore.”
Every voter we talked to says that's why they voted for him.
We shouldn’t be wondering why all these crimes are happening against these people.
Because he's the one saying it’s OK.
He’s the one who said it to begin with.
I just don’t want to see racism back again like we did in the ‘50s and ‘60s.
I remember, I just don’t want to see that again.
Getting on here every day, saying stuff about these people, just to get a sh*tstorm started,
I don’t understand it. I don’t get it.
Running for midterms, I don't know why that should be the number-one thing that they should be talking about,
is the economy and healthcare.
We all worry about healthcare. I mean, everybody will tell you that, probably.
Democrat and Republican.
- Right, exactly.
Trump claims he’s fighting hard against a plan by Democrats
that would destroy Medicare.
I’ve got Medicare. It pays 79% – it could get better.
And you’re not concerned at all that the Republicans might try and change Medicare coverage?
No, I don’t think they will.
In reality, the fund is suffering under his administration.
In June, the government projected Medicare funds would be gone by 2026,
due to low wages and lower taxes.
I come and vote because that's my right,
and do I feel like it's gonna make a difference? No.
Did you feel like he was gonna rock your world?
Yeah, I did.
They don’t want regular politicians …
- They want underdogs.
They want underdogs – somebody that they think will stand up to them.
I think that's all across the country.
Would you vote for Trump again?
Depends on who he's running against.
- Good answer.
Yeah, I think if you had a presidential election – like if you had Trump,
Clinton, Sanders – it would have been a different whole story, probably.
We need more parties. We don’t really need to look at party lines. We need to look at the
people that's running for office.
You voted for Trump, though, in 2016?
I'd rather not say.
If I knew today, after voting for him, that it would pretty much stay the same,
I probably wouldn’t have voted for him.
So when President Trump says Islam hates us,
or he thinks Islam hates us, you believe him?
Yep.
- And you agree that it's a danger?
Yep, I sure do.
And you think that they're trying to take jobs, or that they're trying to do something more sinister?
I think it's more sinister, myself.
- Really.
I don't think the average American really worries about immigrants right now.
I think they're worried more about their family and their livelihood.
I was born in California, but my parents are Middle Eastern.
My parents are Muslim.
And I just wonder – does it change some of what you were thinking,
to know I’m originally Middle Eastern?
Or do you feel it’s the same?
How do you feel about it? You want to kill us off, or what?
I don’t want to kill you. Why would I want to kill you?
I still think you’re a pretty good guy to talk to.
Well, maybe that’s a small step, then.
There’s always steps you gotta take.
What'd you say?
I said, "I wish everybody was like me, then we'd all get along."
I mean, I try to get along with everybody.
But you do have certain people you can't get along with.